Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. There's new Flash
Arrow footage from the crossover next week.
And it implies that Oliver is going to learn
that he really does have a son in Central
City. So we are going to be talking about
some Connor Hawke here because is also supposed
to show up on legends of tomorrow summer to
play these two promo clips but fair warning
the qualitie is kind of janky these are both
rips but the important part is that they give
a big shout out to all of her's child so here
we go
big flashing warning lights going off all
over actually gets to meet his son the real
question is is like what kind of story are
they going to use them for the future because
each season we get like a little bit more
like during season two we learned that he
existed season three we get the teaser during
the big flash arrow crossover season for we
get to see him in person so what are they
gonna do in season five now say all of her
were to take some parenting tips from Malcolm
Merlyn he probably get shipped off to the
league of assassins for training not expecting
that to happen although a version of that
did happen in the comics if you remember way
way back in the comics during the big zero
hour event hell Jordan became infused with
parallax turn into this giant supervillain
and destroy coast city Oliver Queen ended
up trying to kill him and his guilt led him
to go to a special monastery to try try and
wash away the sins like oh my God I kill one
of my best friends later when he found out
about Connor he sent Connor to live with that
monastery not quite the league of assassins
but you get the idea just like you know sending
him a way to quota quote boarding school for
superheroes and because the TV shows exist
in the real world I'm not expecting that to
happen I'm I'm expecting Oliver to try and
have a more normal relationship with his son
all albeit from a distance during these TV
shows flash arrow all these other superheroes
show she recounted demarcate them into different
types of stories you have like the superhero
arc with her trying to defeat a villain some
big plant develop new technology then you
have the personal drama where's the characters
just being normal human beings like you know
you find people you love you get in relationships
with them maybe you have a child at some point
maybe a mystery child my guess is that if
the child survives which I'd I think that
it will it will just slowly move from like
the drama stories to the superhero stories
you can have a superheroes a dad without his
life affecting yours like there's no way you
can have a normal life but as he says the
name of this child is William it is not Connor
the weird thing is going on though is that
it does sound like Connor Hawke is going to
be on legends of tomorrow because the pitch
was is that at some point in the far future
Oliver Queen has fallen and someone has been
inspired to take up the mantle so course that
would be Connor Hawke but it sounds like on
legends of tomorrow that character will not
be all of her son what about this clip so
all of her's child in Central city legends
of tomorrow is going to address the the Batman
thing worth like someone must always wear
the Cal so will see some future green arrow
for those you that have never read the the
green arrow comics Connor Hawke was introduced
in the mid-90s he got rebooted for the new
52 then they brought him back for convergence
that is DC's big event that was going on while
Marvel super horde was happening usually when
he shows up it's like the typical you abandoned
me daddy issues type story not at all like
Damian Wayne and Batman's relationship the
funny thing about Damian Wayne and Batman
is it seems like they have the most positive
father-son relationship of any superhero team
in the DC universe right now is prideful is
Damian is and as withdrawn as Batman's personality
is you still get that they love each other
I don't necessarily that type of relationship
work well on live-action I feel like it's
amazing and animation just because Damian
Wayne is such a cartoony over-the-top character
like that's why people love them so much because
of this really cool heritage that he has in
this very Deadpool lack of care for his immediate
situation like he just he doesn't care about
dangers like whatever I'm Damian Wayne so
I don't necessarily that arrow would choose
to go in that direction with all of her in
any children that he might have put plus his
child seems like it's still under the age
of 10 at this point just because so many things
have to happen before they bring Connor Hawke
on the show if they ever did decide to do
that on arrow I'm in a way little bit to do
a separate Connor Hawke video but if you guys
want me to do that just let me know in the
comments people always make Batman jokes about
arrow see a Queen is really like the Damian
Wayne character that show right now when you
really think about her she's kind of like
a Damian Wayne character with the Mia Dearden
speedy name so she has elements of both of
those characters back stories like she was
resurrected in the Lazarus pit like Damian
Wayne was just this crazy bloodlust and she
has a fairly good relationship with all of
her beard my big question for you guys given
all the things that they're doing with flash
arrow legends of tomorrow of the season would
you ever want to see Connor Hawke on the TV
show I do think that the narrative would be
able to accommodate him or anything of they
did bring them on in the other big characters
like Merlyn are black canary or anybody else
Ray the supporting characters suffer just
because you only have a certain amount of
time in each episode so certain characters
won't get as much screen time is others that's
one of the drawbacks to having like a really
large cast with a lot of the characters you
can only develop a handful of characters each
season and a lot of people been asking about
Laurel this season like what is her story
arc was she brought back her sister but what's
happening now that we know it's there is arc
is gonna be she's going to go on legends of
tomorrow be the white canary is very clear
very laid out but we really don't know what's
happening with Laurel right now Quentin has
a much bigger story arc that Laurel has right
now which also kinda makes me think that he's
marked for death he and Diggle both there
like my two topics for whose can end up in
that grave Paul Blackthorne is an amazing
actor so it would suck if you left the show
but I feel like of all the characters that
you could lose without losing the integrity
of the show he's he's one of the topics like
TV left they just have less stories of the
police station but just reminder next week
flash and arrow big crossover episodes happening
red tornado is coming to Supergirl in Gotham
is having its midseason finale there's going
to be a special Batman view Superman trailer
that's gonna drop during that during the Gotham
episode on Mondays I'll be doing a separate
video for that to be sure to subscribe to
get everything and actually we have a giveaway
winner to name Logan Crede you win the reverse
flash ring giveaway for this week just be
sure to private message me on the back and
my channels and get your contact info I will
start a new round of the giveaway when I post
that first episode of the flash next week
there's been a whole bunch of marvel DC Star
Wars trailers that have posted this week you
can click here for the legends of tomorrow
for all the flash arrow stuff and you can
click here for the Captain America Civil War
trailer if you haven't seen it yet thank you
so much for watching, everybody high five
and I'll see you guys tonight!